we've gotten a few things already
sketched out on the board but let's
actually start with the stack that we
need to get started with you know
modernizing with VMware yeah and IBM
cloud kind of our basic or fundamental
VMware software stack it is quite simple
right you have your bare metal
infrastructure where your environment
runs on right so bare mental infra and
then on top we have your vSphere and so
we actually do automated deployments of
6.5 6.7 and any future releases from a
VMware perspective we have NSX which is
the VMware networking tool and sitting
on top of that kind of the brain of the
whole operations is V Center o is B
Center right and when we look at this
this is just the very basic fundamental
stack there's tons of more components
that you can add for example you can add
V San which is the storage option as
well as any kind of day to operations on
top of the stack gotcha so for an end
user who's coming in and they want to
get started they could just go directly
with V Center and IBM will can automate
and take care of the rest of these
components get them all installed
absolutely everything we do is from an
automation perspective too and we
understand people have different
requirements right I talked about visa
an earlier you know customers you know
prefer other types of storage compared
to V sin or they want to use other
networking tools so they don't actually
even need to use NSX it's just an option
and kind of what we do from a stack
perspective I see ok so we've got a
number of things already sketched out
here like I mentioned and we want to
show kind of I mean really break down
how we modernize from let's say legacy
architecture infrastructure to something
like vmware an IBM cloud so we've got
some things guest up can you kind of
talk through what we have already yeah
absolutely so I think one of the things
we were talking about earlier today was
modernizing means a lot right and one
specific use case I want to look at is
modernizing from legacy hardware and
legacy software and calling out really
VMware HDX so HDX is a migration
hybridity modernization tool whatever
acronym you want to put with that and so
it allows customers actually migrate
from be sphere 5.1 which can be running
on any hardware you want and this is an
old software stack
and so the nice thing that it allows you
to do is actually create a connection
where you can actually go from old
hardware in 5.1 into the newest hardware
in 6.7 and whatever VMware is going to
be releasing in the future mm-hmm and
how it does this it actually makes a
kind of a loosely coupled Network which
allows you to essentially just stretch
your network and that's the really cool
thing is they're kind of stretching your
l2 network it allows you to kind of
create these connections where you can
bring your own IP you can bring your MAC
addresses and the nice thing since
you're bringing those backwards and
forth it really provides us true
hybridity or multi cloud approach right
so essentially all the connections that
the applications may have had previously
so IP address dependencies and those
kinds of things you don't really have to
worry about refactoring or breaking all
those down since you're bringing your
own IP since you're kind of having that
that model those applications continue
to work with each other even though now
you know parts of them are on the cloud
absolutely and and one kind of story
from one of our customers that I love to
talk about is you know we had a customer
running on vSphere 5.0 on old hardware
they were in a doubt in a datacenter in
California and they were looking to try
IBM VMware and IBM cloud and they
actually moved that application from
California all the way to Washington DC
so you're talking across the country and
so obviously with that they increased
latency compared to the other VMs in
their application but that application
actually ran better an IBM cloud you
know even though it was in Washington DC
because it's running on a latest
software and hardware version compared
to what the customer was running on Prem
so the advantages in the compute
basically outweighed that the
disadvantage of having latency across
the country exactly Wow okay and so
that's just kind of one of the use cases
we really like to look at because what
HX allows you to do it cuts this notion
of hey I'm in a monolithic or in you
know legacy at you know Hardware
applications I can't move
HX eliminates that by really providing
that backwards compatibility where you
can take everything you have existing
today and move it into your future state
right so in this kind of example we can
probably say this layer right here or at
least hcx is enabling that excuse me
about that translation so
kind of moving forward so let's say we
have that that hybrid model on Prem and
on the cloud what if we wanted to start
moving some of these assets right so we
want to move those database pieces and
put them over here is that is that
something that HDX would help me do yeah
absolutely so so the beautiful thing
about HX is it allows you to move when
you choose right I can group individual
VMs I can do a live migration I can do
you know planned migration and it
ultimately depends on what the customer
is looking for but really the thing that
we see with HDX and you know any
migration tool it's a lot of it is
analysis paralysis and with what HDX
allows you to do is it allows people to
feel comfortable because you can start
moving one VM to VM and start building
up the comfort of moving you know back
and forth right definitely
so you know with HDX I can run this for
you know let's say however long to make
sure it's stable we're not having any
downtime that you know critical business
workloads are continuing to run and then
once we've kind of already we can start
duplicating some of these assets right
so maybe run some of those DB pieces
over here in the cloud and I would guess
eventually even think about phasing this
portion out absolutely yeah and it's all
a matter of what the customer is looking
for but if you think about from a data
consolidation or a data evacuation use
case that's exactly what we see with HDX
you take what you have existing from an
IP parameter and the nice thing you can
move to the cloud if it doesn't work you
can move it back but if it moves it runs
better you can actually shut down your
own data center and save you know a
significant amount of cost but also get
you to where you want to be right cloud
Multi cloud environment right exactly
so Jordan thank you for breaking this
down for me and our viewers if you have
any questions please drop us a line
below if you want to see more videos
like this in the future please like and
subscribe and don't forget you can
always get started in the cloud at no
cost by signing up for a free IVM cloud
account